hallo klickum hallo Revolver und hallo
Mara also ich habe drei Fragen aber
zuerst möchte ich stolz verkünden dass
ich seit der singleuskpplung von
Generation Rock ein R fin darauf bin ich
stolz und ich kaufe mir jede CD also ich
habe jede CD und ja gekauft und das ist
heutzutage was besonderes nicht ganz
aber doch ja ich find schon okay ich
habe drei Fragen und die Handeln alle um
Youtube von YouTube und ja ich fange an
und ich muss es ablesen ich kann mir das
nicht merken also meine erste Frage ist
wie findet ihr ist das Musiker wie
Justin Bieber durch YouTube berühmt
werden dieses Phänomen dass Musiker ihre
Gesangskünste oder was auch
immer Videos davon bei Youtube hochladen
und plattenfilmen werden auf die
aufmerksam und dann bekommen
Plattenvertrag und so halt euch W das ja
viel schwieriger da gab's ja Youtube
noch nicht und ja damals gab's Youtube
noch
nicht also wir es finden dass Künstler
wie Justin Bieber durch YouTube Erfolg
haben du was dazu sagen sagen ich finde
sowas super dass es diese Möglichkeit
gibt warum nicht jedem das gibt den doch
ihm deutsch ist schwierig für mich sein
Erfolg gibt ihm recht und wenn es durch
Youtube ist oder durch irgendwelche
anderen Online Portale ich meine das ist
die neue das das ist die Zukunft genau
also ich meine es ist ein bisschen wie
MySpace glaube ich youtube dass einfach
auch Leute ohne Plattenvertrag eine
Chance haben das finde ich eigentlich
auch ganz gut letztens war ein ziemlich
lustiges Video das war zwar irgendeine
Werbung aber da da ging um so eine
Geschichte die konnte man komplettieren
indem man irgendein Wort einsetzt und
dann gab es 30 verschiedene Lösungen die
dazu gedreht waren also sowas finde ich
auch super und solche Videos haben auf
Youtube dann ich dachte gleich du sagst
du die Werbung yummy yummy yummy I have
love in my tamumy kenne ich nicht ist
doch so Kinderschokolade ja genau das
ist so
geil Melodie gut die Melodie finde ich
super YUM YUM
YUM nein das ein
uralter ja zumindest haben wir n haben
wir nichts gegen gegen Youtube ne
nächste Frage meine zweite Frage ist es
bei Youtube gibt's ja einige Menschen
die auch Lieder von euchcovert haben und
wie findet ihr es von unbekannten
Menschen gecovert zu werden aber das ist
ja nicht SAS wie wenn jemand auf der
Straße ST ne Lied schon was anderes
finde ich
jedenfalls ja coole sa ja sie ist ganz
cool find ich auchr cool also
grundsätzlich ist es natürlich immer
eine riesen Ehre finde ich wenn wenn
Songs von einem gecovert werden klar und
wenn die dann Videos drehen das auf
Youtube hochstellen wir das lustig wir
haben mal von dem kleinen Kind was
Spinner gesungen hat das Video haben wir
sogar auf unserer Facebookseite gepostet
also wir nehmen sowas schon wahr und
finden das auf jeden Fall lustig ist
doch cool also ich meine ich habe früher
auch viele Sachen nachgespielt hier die
Gitarristen wahrscheinlich noch viel
mehr und wenn es Youtube gegeben hätte
hätte man vielleicht ein Video gedreht
hochgestellt oder bestimmt auf jeden
Fall ja ich finde es auch unglaublich
also ganz eh jeder hat irgendwie
angefangen mal Gitarre zu spielen oder
so und ist do so super dass die dann auf
einmal Songs von uns spielen also ich
meine das ist eine größere Ehre gibt's
ehrlich gesagt nicht da da freuen wir
uns echt ehrlich
drüber ja
amen meine dritte Frage ist seid ihr
selber bei Youtube angemeldet und wenn
ja was macht ihr da also wie aktiv seid
ihr auf Youtube z.B habt ihr da auch
irgendwelche Youtuber abonniert wie z.B
die auusenseiter oder Tutorial odert
oder so oder kennt ihr die überhaupt
wenn nicht dann guckt es euch an das ist
toll und ja das meine dritte Frage und
ich glaube das war's nein das war's doch
nicht weil vor di Jahren habe ich jaob
mal gefragtle
obligatorische Jakob Frage immer Jakob
m na ja ich ich also für Revolver kann
ich auf jeden Fall sagen wir sind
natürlich auf Youtube wir haben da auch
ein Account einfach mal revolverh bei
Youtube eingeben da gibt es einen
eigenen Channel wir machen relativ viel
natürlich laden wir irgendwie alle
unsere Musikvideos da hoch haben aber
auch zum letzten Album sehr viel
Podcasts geschnibbelt und gedreht machen
wir eigentlich immer mal wieder oder was
wir so auf den Festivals erleben und
laden das ab und an mal Youtube hoch und
da gibt's auch mal ziemlich viel
Kommentare und und Klicks und dann
gucken wir uns das auch alles an also es
ist für uns auf jeden Fall echt sinnvoll
voll bei euch ähnlich bei uns sehr
ähnlich und ich schaue immer rein nur
wenn ich irgendwelche Links lustigen
links bekomme von irgendwelchen Freunden
eben Werbespots oder irgendwas lustige
was passiert ist wie yumy yummy yummy
love in my tummy sowas finde ich schon
cool müssen die Geschichte noch zu Ende
hören ne ja ich will das Lied hören y ja
ja vor d Jahren habe ich Jakob mal
gefragt ob ihr mal wieder nach Bochen
kommt also jetzt jetzt R wel also ich
habe Jakob E-Mail geschrieben wann mal
wieder nach bum kommt und dann hat er
mir geantwortet ja dieses Jahr nicht
aber dieses jah irgendwie SAS stand da
drin aber das ist ja schon di Jahre her
und ihr W immer noch nicht in bchum
außer bei der Krone und da bin ich nie
hingekommen weil ich nie Karten gewonnen
habe und ich wollte fragen ob ihr jetzt
noch mal nach bchum kommt oder nicht und
ja ich fin cool wenn ja okay ich gesagt
jetzt tschüss hier noch so blöd weil ich
so viel laber und
na jachum Jakob du hast mit dir
gesprochen ich wann war denn das wann
habt ihr das denn gedreht also aktuell
das ist aktuell ja 24 Oktober da muss
muss man leider sagen hat sie uns
verpasst ja wir auf der bei Bochum Total
gespielt zum zweiten oder dritten Mal
auch glaube ich schon
also einfach regelmäßig revolver.de
checken da sind alle Termine zu finden
wir sind jetzt auch im Dezember noch mal
unterwegs sind leider nicht in Boch in
Recklinghausen sind wir leider glaube
ich Krefeld also schreib mir wieder eine
Mail dann sage ich dir genau wann es ist
und er ist Single
und er ist Single und er
sucht